Kita lihat India, misalnya. Kenapa dia bisa keluar dengan angka nol?
Pada waktu itu, yang kemudian dia adopsi oleh orang Arab dan dibawa ke Eropa.
Kita semua bisa belajar kalkulus, kalau nggak bisa.
Itu semua dahit dari spiritualitas gitu loh, bahwa mereka percaya bahwa
nol itu punya makna, kekosongan itu punya makna, seperti itu.
Maka diberikan lah angka nol, seperti itu.
Nah, Nyayarurukidul itu sebenarnya fungsinya seperti itu.
Memberikan narasi untuknya bisa bertindak.
Bukan untuk dipercayai sebagai entitas yang objektif real seperti itu.
Bukan itu, poinnya. Percaya bahwa itu harus dikemas oleh birokrat-birokrat
yang paham tentang kekuatan epistemologis dari cerita-ceritanya sendiri.
Untuk diangkat menjadi landasan bukan hanya ilmu pengetahuan tapi bertindak.
Kronikos itu punya misi.
Kronikos punya misi untuk memberikan narasi baru buat Indonesia.
Di dunia ini tidak ada binding morality.
Saya tidak percaya ada binding morality.
Mereka, orang-orang, bahkan negara itu bertindak berdasarkan
nasionalisme.
Walaupun di tataran filosofis mereka bisa bilang bahwa liberalisme
atau sosialisme oke tapi begitu ada konflik nasionalisme.
Dan saya percaya bahwa apapun yang berada di dalam negeri
permasalahan ekonomi, permasalahan sosial sangat dipengaruhi
oleh apa yang terjadi di luar Indonesia.
Kemerdekaan kita pun juga sangat dipengaruhi oleh perang Napoleon.
Itu dari dulu itu.
Apalagi sekarang.
Jadi kita tidak bersendirian.
Semuanya terjadi di luar Indonesia.
Jadi untuknya bisa relevan di tengah ketiadaan moral absolut,
Indonesia harus punya narasi yang kuat.
Karena rakyat digerakkan oleh narasi bukan dengan logika.
Walaupun logika itu penting.
Tapi mereka bergerak dengan cerita, dengan narasi.
Apa yang baik, apa yang buruk.
Anak kecil tidak baca jurnal paper.
Mereka baca cerita.
Indonesia itu misinya apa?
Saya sebagai orang Indonesia misinya apa di dunia?
Apakah kita penjaga lingkungan hidup?
Apakah kita poros maritim pikwan?
Dan saya merasa ada kekosongan seperti itu.
Di Indonesia di ketika bicara di kanca internasional tidak punya narasi.
Chronicles percaya bahwa narasi itu datangnya dari identitas.
Kita tidak bisa keluar negeri pakai baju militer bergagah-gagahan bilang kita negara besar.
Tidak ada yang percaya.
Negara besar itu lahir dari identitas.
Dan dari traktor tindakannya.
Jadi seperti itu.
Saya percaya identitas itu ada di level lokal.
Chronicles mencoba untuk mengeluarkan ke luar.
Apa yang menjadi identitas lokal di bugis padang,
atau javanis, sunda.
Mereka sudah punya cerita-cerita itu sendiri.
Dan mereka sangat setia kepada suku-sukunya bahasannya dan warisan dari leluhurnya.
Tapi tidak pernah diangkat di level internasional.
Sedemikian hingga mereka merasa bahwa mereka itu warisan leluhurnya punya signifikasi di dunia akademik.
Bisa menyelesaikan masalah-masalah praktis.
Bahwa orang Bali yang katanya sistem irrigasinya itu berdasarkan hal-hal mistis seperti itu.
Itu sebenarnya punya efikasi yang jauh lebih tinggi daripada sistem irrigasi yang lain.
Mereka bisa secara natural menghentikan hama segala macem.
Itu hal-hal seperti itu yang kita mau angkat.
Nah ketika Indonesia sadar akan identitasnya, punya narasi global baru tindakannya synchron.
Dan saya melihat sekarang belum seperti itu.
Jadi kita melihat ketika representasi dari Indonesia pergi ke luar negeri menyampaikan pesannya,
tidak didukung oleh orangnya sendiri.
Tidak didukung oleh orangnya sendiri.
Indonesia pesannya apa?
Kita penjaga lingkungan hidup. Bagaimana dengan Sawid?
Bagaimana dengan lahan gambut?
Hal seperti itu lah.
Ada ketidak synchronan?
Kalau kita tanya masiswa-masiswa tikat 1 atau anak SMA, apa narasi Indonesia?
Narasi itu harus punya basis untuk melakukan tindakan.
Hal-hal yang seperti kita dengar seperti poros maritim,
atau lumbung pangan internasional atau negara besar, paru-paru dunia,
itu belum komplit.
Negara besar terus mau diapain?
Maksudnya negara besar jangan kritik diri kita sendiri.
Maksudnya itu.
Atau kita paru-paru dunia.
Jadi apa maksudnya?
Jadi kita harus...
Nanam Sawid?
Nanam Sawid atau...
Kalau paru-paru dunia kok nanam Sawid?
No, no, no.
People buy authenticity.
Oke.
Pesan kita harus sesuai dengan pola hidup dan tindakan yang otentik.
Dan otentisitas itu lahir dari identitas.
Kita tidak mengenal orang Jawa.
Kita tidak mengenal orang Bugis.
Di level pusat kita tidak mengenal mereka.
Contohnya,
Yogyakarta itu punya...
Pepatahnya sendiri.
Hameh Mayu, Ayuning Baywono.
Manusia itu untuk mempercantik alam semesta yang sudah cantik.
Ada semacam ethos lingkungan hidup di situ.
Mereka sangat menghormati
Sumbuk kosmologikal dari gunung Merapi sampai ke laut selatan.
Sekarang dengan Openin Buslow misalnya.
Izin-Izin untuk melakukan eksplorasi
Pasir di gunung Merapi.
Itu langsung dari pusat.
Bukan dari mereka.
Hal-hal detail seperti itu harus menghormati
Kebudayaan lokal.
Karena pada dasarnya saya tidak akan menikmati
Ilmu Bumi di Imperial College atau di U.K.
Tanpa ketika pada jaman 18, 19, 100an
Itu para naturalis belajar tentang volkanologi,
Tentang di Earth Crust.
Itu dari masyarakat Jawa.
Dan narasi-narasi seperti itu lain kita.
Mungkin malu kali mas.
Mungkin malu untuk keluarkan.
Bahwa sebenarnya kita punya jawapan akan masalah-masalah praktis.
Kenapa?
Kalau benar-benar saya sih,
Reaction saya itu karena
Sejujurnya sejujurnya.
Oke.
Malaka.
Tan malaka.
Historikal
Materialisme.
Mereka ingin ngomong-ngomong.
Historikal materialisme.
Ide.
Dia bicara banyak tentang feudalisme.
Dia mengadopsi materialisme Marxist
Dari tadinya kelas karena kapitalisme.
Tapi diaplikasikan dalam konteks feudalisme.
Dan ide tentang di mana lokasi Indonesia dalam
Global Conversation.
Itu lahirnya dari
Klas Warfare.
Antara yang menjajah dengan yang dijajah.
Itu kita tidak bisa singkirkan dalam semalam.
O penjajahnya pergi, ide nya hilang.
Jadi ratusan tahun Klas Warfare
Itu membekas di dalam diri kita sampai sekarang.
Termanifestasi dari cara kita berdiri kalau ngambil foto.
Cara kita memposisikan diri ketika ngomong dengan orang luar negeri.
Itu tidak hilang serta merta.
Mental inlander.
Mental seperti itu tidak hilang dalam semalam.
Ini menarik nih Mas.
Aku sepakat dengan bagian
Kita kekurangan alasi sebagai sebuah bangsa.
Yang lebih seperti itu kan.
Dan banyak hambatan obsekle nya seperti rasa malu tadi.
Ratusan tahun feudalisme dan lain sebagainya.
Di beberapa aspek ketika kita membicarakan sesuatu.
Apalagi membicarakan budaya lokal ini kan sentuhan yang banyak sekali kan.
Setelah masuk hal yang sering.
Yang belakangan aku bakal hasil itu hal-hal yang berusaha dengan klinik.
Mistik dan juga macam-macam.
Aku agen sama hal kayak gitu.
Tapi orang sering salah memahami.
Oh berarti lu mau membunuh budaya lokal.
Tidak seperti itu.
Cuman aku mau nanya ke Mas Bagus yang memang lebih
Lebih mendalami hal-hal seperti ini kan.
Lebih memang
Intulah dengan budaya lokal.
Yang aku orang minang.
Yang memang udah hidup dengan budaya seperti itu juga.
Ada hal-hal yang emang
Ketika kita mau ngambil hal baiknya ini Mas.
Gimana kita memintikasi
Memintikasi hal-hal buruk yang bisa terjadi atas itu.
Misalnya miskosepsi ilmiah.
Gimana caranya?
Apa solusi yang bisa kita ambil
Ketika kita tidak melukai ini.
Tapi di satu sisi
Kayak aku pernah dengar Mas Bagus cerita soal.
Laut adalah Nyeroro Kidul itu sendiri.
Itu sebuah
Sebuah statement yang luar biasa dan Bagus sekali gitu.
Dan aku yakin orang Intulah dan Enggit sama itu.
Tapi bagaimana
Mitigasi yang harus kita lakukan
Supaya orang
Memahami itu sebagai bentuk preventif
Atas kulusakan hal-hal yang sebagainya.
Bukan memahami itu dengan
Oh berarti gue harus menumbalkan sapi di laut.
Ini sangat sulit dipahami karena
Layernya beda-beda.
Ada yang paham bahwa yang saya maksud itu adalah
Epistemolikal
Utiliti gitu. Bukan berarti saya bilang bahwa
Nyeroro Kidul itu pada waktu itu ada.
Seperti itu ya.
Nomor satu ini karena
Para akademisi tidak mendidik
Masyarakat
Dengan seharusnya
Saya tahu persis dan saya ngikutin
Tuna seri itu segala macem.
Saya suka itu.
Itu juga saya merupakan korban ya.
Waktu kecil juga banyak orang kesurupan.
segala macem orang percaya itu kita tahu.
Kita paham.
Dan kerugian, bahkan kerugian nyawa
oleh orang-orang Indonesia yang percaya
Kan hal itu akhirnya kehilangan nyawa
Banyak sekali.
Jadi begini
Bisa kak kita
Nomor satu sebelum saya jawab ke solusinya.
Bisa kak kita menghilangkan 100%
Spiritualitas dalam Indonesia tidak mungkin.
Ya kan?
Universitas lahirnya dari mana?
Maksud saya begini.
Ketika kita bicara tentang masalah real seperti
Climate Change
Ilmu pengetahuan tidak bisa berdiri sendiri.
Ilmu pengetahuan dalam hal ini
Visikal, biologi, matematik.
Tidak pernah masuk dalam domain etis.
Gak mau ke situ ya saya.
Tapi poinnya adalah
Untuk mereka bisa menjadi
Potent Force
Harus ada
Ethical underlying disitu.
Bahwa ok kita tahu caranya
Menyerap karbon.
Dan kita punya tanggung jawab
Katak siapa?
Gimana caranya membuktikan kita punya tanggung jawab
Di dalam laboratorium?
No, kita tidak bisa melakukan itu.
Itu lahir dari
Ethos, etik
Spiritualitas itu.
Gak bisa dibuktikan dalam laboratorium.
Gak bisa dijelaskan dalam empiris.
Terus kalau pawang hujan gimana?
Berarti gak bisa dijelaskan.
Berarti kita harus percaya.
Nah ini begini.
Gimana cara kita menentukan
Probabilitas sebuah klaim supernatural?
Mana yang harus dipercaya?
Mana yang tidak bisa dipercaya?
Sebagai seorang matematik,
Kawan, salah satu yang saya jadi
Kandujukan itu yang disebut Bayesian theory.
Bayesian theory bukan orang matematik.
Mungkin orang ekonomi juga tahu ya.
Bayesian theory itu kan
Landasannya Turing Machine.
Waktu Alan Turing
Mecahin Enigma itu.
Bayesian theory.
Ini agak teknis.
Tapi saya ngomong begini.
Dalam konteks seperti pawang hujan,
Pertanyaannya adalah
Berapa besar kemungkinan
Hipotesa sama pawang hujan itu benar
Melihat
Bukti-bukti yang ada.
Oke.
Fair question.
Gimana cara ngukurnya?
Kemungkinan adanya hujan itu
Harus dikalikan
Banyak hujan karena hipotesanya benar
Dibagi
Probabilitas adanya hujan
Walaupun hipotesanya salah.
Itu baru menurut
Orts form of Bayesian theory
Hasilnya
Probabilitas hujan karena hipotesa
Sangpawang hujan itu betul.
Ini agak kompleks. Mungkin nanti bisa ditulis.
Persamaannya.
Nah yang orang lihat
Di lapangan adalah
Sangpawang hujan menaruh
Kemudian hujan
Maka dia benar
Yang tidak pernah
Masukkan dalam persamaan itu adalah
Apakah hari itu toh akan hujan
Apakah hujan
Walaupun hipotesanya salah
Dua pembanding ini gak pernah dimasukkan
Dan secara scientific kita
Bisa uji
Klaim-klaim seperti itu, gak cuman sekali
Tapi bisa di uji misalnya
Dia bikin klaim sekali.
Hujan atau tidak. Dia bikin klaim sekali
Probabilitasnya naik di atas 20%
Tapi kedua kali dia klaim
Dan tidak hujan, probabilitynya turun
Dari 20 bisa jadi di bawah 1%
Seperti itu.
Nah hal-hal seperti itu
Mesinnya di
Komunikasikan pada masyarakat
Itulah yang membedakan mengapa
Pawang hujan itu
Tidak credible secara scientific
Tapi klaim-klaim supernatural
Seperti adanya Tuhan
Atau
Kalau di dunia Christian kebangkitan
Yesus segala macem
Berbeda dari segi
Probabilitas itu, dan dari segi itu agak kompleks
Poyen saya adalah
Dari segi matematis
Orang harusnya bisa punya
Alat
Untuk berpikir
Menganalisa apakah ini masuk akal atau tidak
Ketika
Di dunia
Hukum
Misalnya
Kamu membunuh
A
Karena apa argumentnya?
Karena pada waktu jam 9 malam
Kamu ada di situ
Sidik jari kamu ada di dalam pisau
Yang masuk ke dalam badan dia
Yang menyebabkan yang mati
Dan kamu tetap di situ selama 10 menit
Ya kan?
Oke, sebenarnya bukan begitu
Waktu itu saya menggapikkan pisau nya
Tapi tiba-tiba
Alam semesta bergetar
Terus kemudian hujan lebat turun
Ada petir menyambar-nyambar
Kemudian ada suara aneh dari langit
Yang kemudian mengambil pisau dari tangan saya
Kemudian dengan sendirinya dia masuk
Ke dalam si A
Itu sebenarnya penjelasannya
Kemudian
Jadi oh itu tidak bisa dibuktikan
Di dalam laboratorium tidak untuk dipercaya
Bukan begitu
Dunia hukum mengerti bahwa itu
Tidak bisa dipercaya, bukan karena tidak ada
Spiritualitas
Penjelasannya miskin dengan rasional
At-hoc
Contrife
Dan kalau kita lihat
Persamaan Bayesian itu
Terlihat di situ
Berapa besar kemungkinan
Bahwa pada waktu itu ada hujan
Menyambar segala macem
Tapi akademisi tidak
Dedik orang untuk
Percaya seperti itu
Untuk bisa menganalisa secara
Berapa besar kemungkinannya
Di hal-hal seperti itu
Mengenai nyaiyorokidul
Saya tidak pernah punya argument
Bahwa nyaiyorokidul itu betul-betul ada
Oke, poinnya bukan di situ
Tapi ketika ada orang yang
Nangkap argument masih bagus seperti itu
Apa yang harus kita lakukan
Bagaimana memitigasi hal seperti itu
Orang harus mengerti
Apa yang disebut ontologi
Apa yang disebut epistemologi
Oke
Kita lihat India
Misalnya dan
Tan Malkan tulis tentang India juga
Kenapa dia bisa keluar
Dengan angkat nol
Yang kemudian dia adopsi oleh orang Arab
Dan dibawa ke Eropa
Kita semua bisa belajar kalkulus
Kalau tidak, tidak bisa
Itu semua dahit dari spiritualitas
Bahwa mereka percaya bahwa
Nol itu punya makna
Kekosongan itu punya makna
Yang akan diberikan
Nah, nyaiyorokidul
Itu sebenarnya fungsinya seperti itu
Memberikan narasi untuk
Bisa bertindak
Bukan untuk dipercayai sebagai entitas
Yang objektif real seperti itu
Ya, bisa
Nah, seperti itu, nyaiyorokidul jelas-jelas tidak bisa
Dibuktikan secara
Historis
Betul-betul ada
Tapi poinnya bukan di situ
Poinnya adalah dia membuat
Itu mengerti caranya bertindak
Dengan eksistensi
Dia dalam narasi
Akhirnya orang tahu apa yang mau dilakukan
Di zaman itu ya
Di zaman itu dia bisa melakukan
Dia bisa memitigasi bencana alam
Karena dipandang bahwa nyaiyorokidul
Dengan penunggu gunung merapi itu berhubungan
Beralian si, dibilangnya
Ketika ada gemuruh dari laut
Maka sebentar lagi akan disusul oleh gunung berapi
Dan kemudian tahun 1960an
Kapal ekspedisi sains dari Amerika
Menemukan bahwa di sekitaran
Sungai Opak di situ
Yang di antara sumbu
Akses kosmologi dari Jogjakarta
Ada jalur makhmatik di situ
Kita masih sadar
Sainsifik enterprise yang kita mengerti
Sekarang itu umurnya belum lama, mas
Ya, tapi yang hal-hal kayak gini nih
200 tahun dibandingkan 300 juta
Sejarah manusia
200 tahun itu hanya sebuah penuh
0,000,000 sekian
Pada waktu itu orang mengerti alam semesta itu
Dengan-dengan metode yang kita pelajari sekarang
Ada jamannya dulu
Orang mengerti alam semesta dengan memberikan
Antitas humanoid
Diberikan nama
Tapi mereka mengerti
Tentang
Gerakan-gerakan tektonic dengan mengambil
Sempol di tempat-tempat yang ada sesajiannya di situ
Namanya Yerorokidul
Lantas
Kita mau buang itu semua
Kita mau buang itu semua dan
Maksudnya menjadi semacam hal yang
Tidak berguna
Dan saya percaya
Bukan itu poinnya
Percaya bahwa itu harus dikemas
Oleh birokrat-birokrat yang paham
Tentang kekuatan epistemologis
Dari cerita-ceritanya sendiri
Untuk diangkat
Menjadi landasan bukan hanya ilmu pengetahuan
Tapi bertindak
Landasan itu
Sultan Hamanku Buono
Kesembilan
Mereka bukan
Bukan
Mereka bukan orang yang sederhana
Mereka sederhana
Dia bukan
Sesajianan
Dia mengerti bedanya
Narasi
Mistis dengan dunia modern
Orang Jawa
Tidak bingung sebenarnya
Bedanya antara
Sesajianan dengan hal-hal praktis
Mereka tidak bingung
Kalau mereka sekarang yang masih berada di tataran
Tidak teredukasi
Kemudian termakan
Paradukun segala macem
Itu sebenarnya refleksi yang lebih besar
Dari ketidak efektifan
Pendidikan Indonesia
Berarti
Batam lain sama benang-benang merahnya
Nyambung
Dan kamu melakukan kerja yang baik
Kamu mencoba itu, kan?
Siapa yang mau santai saya, silakan itu
Itu sangat menyerahkan
Kamu menonton konten-konten yang bagus
Karena aku menganalysis
Mereka menganalysis market
Dan dari naras umbernya sendiri
Apa yang dimasukkan sama mas bagus
Tadi kan sudah dijelasin cara jelas
Gimana narasi itu dibungkus
Bukan dimatikan total
Ini kan sudah 100 juta tahun
Dan itu juga jadi basis
Orang yang tidak sekolah untuk bertindak
Yang terbaik dalam semua pilihan
Tidak kan dalam sebagainya
Terus ketika aku melihat
Sama seperti ini, mas
Aku kasih penjelasannya yang lebih enak mungkin
Ada satu channel di YouTube
Namanya rumah Heditor
Tapi yang dia bahas itu fisika
Fisika lanjutkan bahkan kuantum
Dan dia sudah faham
Ketika gue mau menjelaskan
Kuantum dengan enak dan bisa
Enggat sama orang, gue bahas santai
Iya, banyak
Jadi
Spooky in the distance
In-stain
Sama beberapa teori
Kuantum lainnya
Kita yang belajar kuantum, gak seperti itu
Nah
Akhirnya dia menjelaskan
Syara fisik, mungkin
Kau antara satu atom sama satu atom lainnya
Terkoneksi, bukan mungkin
Terlihat
Kalo penjelasan via kuantum
Ternyata
Di Indonesia
Video itu ramai mas, bayangin kita bahas
Fisika kuantum bisa dapat 4 juta views
Tapi
Aku
90% orang yang ngomong di video itu
Akhirnya nangkap melakukan simplifikasi
Akhirnya nangkap, tuh kan, santai, hadap
Nah, dari situ aku ngeliat
Kayaknya memang metode paling benar ya
Narasi konten narasi
Betul
Jadi narasi konten narasi
Kalo aku menjelaskan pake pendekatan antrop
Enggak akan selesai gitu
Maksudnya dengan sesejati yang segede
Dengan sesejati yang kayak gini
Ya secara
Solomon udah ngomong kayak gini
Akhirnya orang
Sudahlah, skip aja
Radikalisme itu tidak dilawan
Dengan memberikan akses informasi
Sebesar-besarnya, bukan
Justru malah makin radikal
Radikalisme itu dilawan
Seperti yang Mas Ferry bilang
Counter-naratif
Narasi dilawan
Narasi, gitu loh
Justru ini misi dari
Yang saya lakukan di Indonesia bersama teman-teman
Dua sen yang lain
Oke, nyaira ruki dulu
Apa kita akan lakukan tentangnya?
Ini tempat yang terlebih dahulu
Ini ada
Ada landasan yang elegan dari situ
Ilmu bumi yang modern itu tumbuh dari situ
Supaya masyarakat mengerti
Jadi, narasi-narasi seperti ini lah
Yang harus mengimbangi
Bahwa ada santai Tuhan segala macem
Mereka harus dididik
Untuk memahami budaya mereka sendiri
Bukan diberikan semata-mata
Walaupun baik ya
Akses ini semuanya punya internet
Semuanya punya akses ke Twitter
Tidak, Twitter adalah sebuah dunia panjang
Narasi-narasi di situ makin
Rewah gitu kan
Kalau misalnya di UK
Ada radikalisme
Ada juga di UK
Masalah-masalah yang garis keras
Gala macem gitu ya
Nomor satu, kata pertama yang berada di dalam
Asia punya anak
Jadi, dia di dalam sekolah
Public di situ ya
Kita akan melawannya dengan counter-naratif
Dan di UK itu punya counter-naratif
Karena identitasnya kuat sekali
Bagaimana dia punya etos
Tentang apa yang baik dan benar
Oke, dari hamlet misalnya
Perjuangan seorang pangeran
Yang dikianati oleh pamannya
Kemudian dia melakukan perjalanan
Layaknya seorang pahlawan
Dia melakukan hal-hal yang mulia
Akhirnya dia mendapatkan glory
Itu hamlet karya Shakespeare
Diturunkan menjadi layan-king
Buat anak-anak, layan-king itu hamlet
Oh itu basisnya hamlet
Basisnya hamlet, cuma diubah aja
Dari orang jadi singa
Basisnya hamlet
Itu sama persis ya
Iya, tidak sama persis
Ya, ada paktisnya
Ada babinya segala-mahanya
Aku berkata, ya, terima kasih
Itu, cerita-cerita itu dikultifasi
Anak-anak tahu, misalnya pada waktu itu
Inggris punya kegelapan
Di mana jutaan orang, tidak tahu jutaan atau ribuan
Meninggal karena Black Plague
Black Death, dibilangnya
Nyanyian anak-anak itu
Itu ada yang berdasarkan hal itu
Kalau si Mary
Memulai tanda-tanda seperti ini
Sementara lagi, dia akan mati segala-macem
Itu loh
Nah, Indonesia kekurangan cerita-cerita seperti itu
Makanya saya bicara dengan
Profesor Nur Hayati Rahman
Dari Makhasar
So, umur hidupnya di dedikasikan
Untuk menerjemahkan, mendigitalitasikan
Kita pelaga Ligo
Di situ, dia pakai hidupnya
Untuk
Meng-Un-Earth, gitu ya
Sebuah kitab yang panjangnya 1,5 kali lipat
Dari Mahabarata, di dalamnya ada
Eto seorang Bugis
Di dalamnya ada jawapan
Tentang apa yang harus orang Bugis
Lakukan terhadap masalah climate
Sebenarnya bahwa
Manusia itu diciptakan
Sebagai produk dari
Menikahnya
Penunggu atau Dewa dari Langit
Dengan Dewa dari Bawah Laud
Permasalahnya bukan ya
Apakah benar demikian?
Udah lah ya
Udah lah, gitu loh
Poinnya adalah
Orang tahu fungsinya
Adalah untuk menjaga
Kesiimbangan Laud dan Langit
Bahkan untuk buang air kecil pun di Laud
Dia nggak berani
Apalagi mencemarinya dengan minyak
Gitu loh
Oke, maaf
Ya seperti itu
Menarik itu di Indonesia itu
Ketika kita bikin di Tong Sampa
Di tempat pembohongan Sampa
Di hutan, misalnya
Jangan buang Sampa di sini
Jaga kebersihan
Orang masih buang Sampa
Tapi kalau ditulis yang buang Sampa di sini
Banyak kuntilanak
Persih itu tempat
Nah itu refleksi lagi
Saya juga masih belajar
Apa sih yang membuat orang melakukan sesuatu
Apa sih basis dari tindakannya
Dan waktu saya pertama kali
Belajar matematik segala macem
Saya juga melalui fase di mana
Oh, orang harus tahu
Tentang ilmu pengetahuan segala macem
Ujung-ujung ya
Ilmu pengetahuan itu
Satu dari berbagai variabel dalam persamaan
Yang membuat orang melakukan tindakan
Variabel yang lebih besar itu dalam narasinya
Oke
Sebenarnya landasan etisnya
Terima kasih sudah menonton